foreign
we're celebrating the one year
anniversary Ken of the borrowed future
launch and we're going to Premiere the
film on YouTube for the very first time
very exciting Monday October 17th 7 P.M
Central we're going to have a watch
Party on YouTube so you can go to our
Ramsey Show highlights Channel and hit
notify me and that'll be your RSVP there
and this is our award-winning
documentary if you don't know but I
didn't know about it that uncovers the
dark side of the student loan industry
every high schooler needs to watch this
every parent needs to watch this you've
got to share this with people in your
life that you care about and you can
follow the watch party on October 17th
you can view it on YouTube for free on
demand beyond that of course with ads if
it's on YouTube so here's what Bard
future does folks it shows you multiple
stories that really illustrate the
question we just read this idea that the
law degree is this you know this magical
ticket but and what it really is is a
carrot and it's dangling and it's
tempting and it it says one thing and it
does something completely different it
wrecks lives when you cannot afford to
pay it back oh yeah and it is uh it's a
nightmare you're gonna see these
nightmares In Living Color it is a
jarring uh but also hope filled
documentary we're very very proud of it
and I have the next emotions the watch
parties I mean you're hanging out here
uh at the offices on a couch with
popcorn I tried to get deloney and I to
hang out and get some popcorn I don't
think he was interested but if you are
I'm happy to show up at the Coleman's
house oh should we as long as it's at my
house and I don't have to go anywhere
just your backpack they're just gonna
bring cameras in and and and then are
they live our reactions are they filming
us like Mystery Science Theater Company
we would have to pay people to watch
that it's the opposite effect I don't
think that's true I think the people
would love for us to be piped in a
little small window uh and we were
commenting on on things
we could press pause and go on a rant do
you know what I'm saying oh my God plus
I think people would want to know what
kind of popcorn you would eat versus the
popcorn that I would eat which is I'm
going with something a little healthier
not the one that's sopping from the
microwave with the movie theater butter
you know I've got standards in my life I
know what would it be you're probably
the light pocket guy what do I see it's
organic I'm gonna do my own salt on
there
very bougie see I'm going Orville
Redenbacher I'm a man of the people
extra movie butter when I pull my hands
out you can see the butter kind of
trickling down the side of my finger see
I'm a man of the people no thanks Tom
Hanks George wants corn with the story
it was free range yes it had a life I
want it on the stove I want to be a
Little House on the Prairie making my
popcorn from scratch I wanted to make my
belly feel good that's all I care about
what it's gonna do you you got too much
thinking going on well popcorn or not I
want everyone to watch this and it's
gonna be fun the watch party hit the
details again it's going to be great fun
on October 17th 7 P.M Central it's a
Monday night you can watch it on YouTube
for free for the premiere and then
beyond that we're gonna have it with ads
of course on YouTube for free you can
still watch it without ads on Amazon
Prime Apple TV Google Play
ramsaysolutions.com you can rent it
there for just a few bucks but this has
started to disrupt this toxic student
loan industry you know all the pieces
involved the guidance counselors the
parents the colleges who have been
raising prices at an insane rate and so
we dig into all that there's stories of
heartbreak there's inspiring stories of
folks who did it debt free including our
friend Christina Ellis that's exactly
right by the way uh this this
documentary is right in the center of of
what I believe are two perfect storms
that are coming and let me tell you what
the storm is creating there's a
different tide if you will George a wave
coming in and I just uh put this on my
Instagram account College enrollment is
down nearly 10 percent over the last two
years only 51 percent of gen Z teams
George are considering a four-year
degree that's a 20-point drop since May
2020.
uh the college is the only way to
succeed wave is going out and the no
degree required wave is coming in and
and these this is the situation because
here's what we're seeing with young kids
on their own they're saying I don't know
if the time or the money is worth it to
do what it is that I want to do these
kids are sharper than we give them
credit for so the you take that the
legitimacy and credibility of the degree
being questioned by young kids and then
the overwhelming crushing cost of
tuition stressing parents out and the
student loan crisis all of those those
two storms coming together uh oh watch
out higher ed Ramsey Solutions is right
there in the middle to help you out this
is the Ramsey Show